poland says seven police officers were
hurt in violent clashes with migrants at
its border with belarus yesterday polish
security forces used tear gas and water
cannons against migrants trying to enter
the country belarus is accused of
facilitating and orchestrating this
crisis as retaliation against sanctions
a charge the country denies our charlie
dagetta is near the poland belarus
border where it is cold and getting
colder winter is coming charlie good
morning
it is coming tony good morning to you
yes poland's defense minister said
migrants have continued to attack that
border fence again overnight those are
his words and he warns the standoff
could last for months
the escalating migrant crisis at the
border may be of belarus's making but
the apparent plan to use migrants as a
human battering ram has turned both
sides into a battlefield
polish police firing water cannon
volleys of tear gas and a hail of rubber
bullets sent refugees into retreat
poland's harsh treatment of migrants has
compounded the suffering of the most
vulnerable people already living in
medieval conditions in sub-freezing
temperatures
we are like a ball like a ball in the
stadium
belarus and poland
they kick us
polish border forces said this morning
they had detected 161 attempts at
illegal crossing including two forceful
attempts to cross the border overnight
for those migrants who do manage to get
across a different nightmare awaits
hiding out in the forest dodging police
who will haul them back to the border
and it feels like you're abandoning them
it's and they they beg for help yes
and i cannot do anything anna albot is a
polish aid worker who's helped refugees
all over the world now the crisis is
unfolding on her doorstep there is
probably around thousand five hundred
people right now in the polish forests
those are people who need everything who
need food who needs water who needs
medicine clothes they have nothing right
now
the polish government has forbidden aid
agencies from entering the exclusion
zone along the border and it's teeming
with 20 000 security forces to turn back
anybody who tries
we have to stop it we have to force
polish government to let international
organizations humanitarian organizations
to get into the zone to give people
absolutely at least water and food we
can't look away
we can look away
now there is some news to report we're
hearing this morning from polish
officials that migrants inside that
border camp in belarus are starting to
being bust away and that the camp is
slowly emptying it is unclear where
they're headed gail
charlie jagged reporting from poland
that was a very descriptive analogy he
gave guys we're like a ball in a stadium
getting kicked back and forth yeah not a
place you want to be no that's not good
for anybody